c'est parti
histoire du lieu où comment noyer le
poisson cette compagnie de théâtre
nantaise va nous faire redécouvrir saint
quentin en yvelines lors d'une visite
pour le moins atypique entre histoire et
humour on est dans plein de registres
différents j'aime bien changer de
registre à chaque spectacle est celui là
cet est d'aborder la ville sur un ton
humoristique quoi de relire la ville
sous un angle absurde en mêlant le vrai
il faut donc nous on vient sur le site
sur la ville on se renseigne sur
l'histoire du lieu d'où le titre on
prend un personnage qui a existé dans le
passé mais qu'est ignorer ce personnage
c'est l'abbé picard à l'origine de la
construction des canaux qui ont servi à
alimenter versailles au xviie siècle
comment se laver et faire ça le cir
quand on a
cinq visites gratuites sont organisées
samedi et dimanche à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine
alors rendez vous devant le musée de la
ville à montigny pour tenter de démêler
le vrai du faux